whatever told you that owning a brand
new 65-inch oled tv within reasonable
course has just become a reality
with prison plus entering the fray
a lot more folks are going to enjoy the
greatest leap in display tech so much so
that going back to any other display
feels like a downgrade but at what cost
hello everyone i'm gerald and today i
will be reviewing the prism plus
65al oled tv we cover plenty of topics
at geek culture so the next video might
be different from this so before you go
thanks for dropping by hang around and
subscribe if the content tickles your
fancy upfront if you are looking for
brand new tv and have been lasting for
an oled in particular the new prism plus
oled tv is the brand of choice if cost
is a major concern with this particular
65 inch model priced at about 2799
dollars an alternative from lg in the
form of the 65-inch lg c1 can be
obtained for
3699 singapore dollars price wise it's
an easy pick
today we're gonna find out if cheaper is
better and what are the main points to
take note of in this budget oled tv if
price is a concern this is the tv made
for you for most folks who are looking
for brand new tv the word oled gets
flooded around a lot
after all
these oled panels are made only by lg
display and they supply a good deal of
tv brands around the world
now prism plus has gotten whole of these
panels and are looking to pass on the
savings to the customer with a few oled
and oled variants out there in the
market the customer has a hard time
deciding whether a cheaper oled tv from
prism plus might be a wise choice
i've used this tv across all my content
consumption mostly in the space of
streaming services youtube and gaming
and i'm confident that prism plus will
be a good starting point before one
works up the course ladder
the prism plus 65 al comes with most
essentials that one might be looking for
in an oled tv
we have dolby vision adobe atmos hdr10
and it's powered by android tv
this tv has a resolution of 3840 by 2160
a refresh rate of 60 hertz in a 65 inch
display
in line with most modern tv designs the
display bezels are extremely thin and as
a teaspoon finish that does not scream
for attention this tv speaks volumes to
its performance and that's all it really
needs
when it comes to hardware design of the
tv prism plus has been taking notes hdmi
ports and a power cord are all tucked to
the side which allow for quick access
and stress-free wall mounting as well
focusing on the oled display i found no
issues with the color and contrast on
this panel
well there might be a possibility that i
have been provided with a pre-selected
optimal panel for review by prism plus
do make sure to give this tv a proper
test once you have it on hand so far the
oled panel is bright and i've been
entirely impressed that prism plus has
been able to pull this off at this price
point
in testing the contrast each region is
as it should be
whites do not have a hint or gray nor
blue and the same holds true when it
comes to color accuracy what struck me
was how bright the whites were in this
scene in moonlight those words on the
shelf the birth of western civilization
has a strong contrast and it really pops
out in the scene the tv's blacks are
delivered as crisp as we would expect
from an oled panel whether you're using
the display in bright sunlight or in a
dim room
this tv continues to perform with
consistency for the best experience i
would recommend to use a 4k apple tv
because the biggest weakness of the tv
is the lack of a competent tv os to go
along with the display
talking about awesome peripherals let's
talk about today's sponsor here at geek
culture we love our keyboards especially
with the all new logitech mx keys mini
an elegant and functional keyboard its
ultra responsive rounded keycaps are
super stable and quiet for more
productivity there are buttons to enable
dictation microphone audio control and
emojis the backlit keys illuminate when
you get close and matches the lighting
of the environment you're in it lasts up
to 10 days on a full charge or 5 months
with the backlights turned off to find
out more about the logitech mx keys mini
and their latest range of products head
over to logitech.com and now let's head
back to more chill vibes android tv os
is pretty dated at this point of time
and google tv os is currently not
available on the tv do yourself a favor
and leave the heavy content processing
to the apple tv in order to get the best
visuals from the display
the next biggest concern here is the
lack of hdmi 2.1 support for anyone who
is looking to play their ps5 or xbox
series x will be missing the best of
what the modern console has to offer
however the tv's refresh rate caps out
at 60 hertz so there's little reason to
get this tv if you are an avid gamer
otherwise with the help of toby the tv
sounds excellent at high volumes but it
does suffer at softer levels
[Music]
[Applause]
for most folks you want to pair it with
your preferred soundbar to get the most
out of this tv it's a common issue that
plagues most tvs that are built so thin
that some additional help is essential
to ensure your experience is maximized
at this point we do get an idea of the
extent of features hd prism plus
65al is able to cut down in order to
keep costs low with the lack of vrr
g-sync freesync and all the fancy
features we see in the top tier oled tvs
might keep the tv purist away
when it comes to the actual main oled
panel itself prism plus has ensured that
you'll be able to get the best out of
the display with a comprehensive picture
calibration manual one would benefit
from a professional to help calibrate
the tv to the best possible settings
going into the menus to take some time
to adjust all the settings to your
heart's content to make sure you're
satisfied prism plus has set the default
option to vivid and i found that content
does not seem over tuned unlike other tv
manufacturers for her tv at this size
it's hard to find anything else that
matches up in terms of performance and
cost
what you might be missing out for all
will be a fancy and snappy operating
system
and a nice motion controller if you are
willing to live with that the prism plus
65al oled tv is definitely the tv to get
if you are on a budget and desire to
enter the oled family
at this price i cannot tell how anyone
can really complain if prism plus is
falling short of expectations with the
absence of a proper tv os an apple tv
would be a great accessory for the
display
if you're an avid gamer this is not
something you want to pick up if you're
gaming on a ps5 or xbox series x
because the lack of a hdmi 2x1 port
makes it hard to deploy the console's
future potential outside of that this tv
is a definite winner with that said i'm
gerald from geek culture and i'll be
happy to answer any questions about the
tv in the comment section below
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you